- Good morning, Believe Nation,
today's message is experiment.
Over to you, Elie Goulding.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- It's key to everything,
or it's key to what I do.
I wouldn't be here without
experimenting like crazy.
I like so many different
types of music and I hope that
I could get away with including
all of those different
influences on my first
record, and I think I got away
with it and maybe on my second as well.
But I mean like, I would
say that I'm a pop artist
and play pop music, but it's not without
a lot of experimentation and
also risking writing something
that maybe isn't very good
or is silly, you know.
My voice is my instrument,
so sometimes I sing things
that just sound crazy, but
then one take out of 20
will be really, really
cool and I keep that one
and then that's that,
so yeah, experimentation
is everything for me as a musician.
- I think extermination
is that the key to success
not just as a musician, not
just as an entrepreneur,
but in general, in life,
you need to experiment.
You need to take the ideas
that you have in your head
and go out and try stuff because
if you are not experimenting,
then what's happening?
Then you're just living life by the book,
you're just doing things that
other people tell you to do.
You're doing the same things
over and over and over
and over and over again,
you're not trying anything new
and so your life becomes
this boring repetition day
in and day out and that sucks,
especially as a creative
entrepreneur who wants to go
out and make a difference.
So I want to address what
I feel holds people back
from trying from experimenting.
The first part is I think
people are just afraid
of being judged, they're
afraid of failing,
they're afraid of putting
themselves out there
and trying something new
and it not working out
and people are going to laugh at them
or they're going to be embarrassed
and that is not the way to live your life.
If you look at successful
people, the further and further
ahead they get, right, the more
and more success they have,
you'll find that those
super successful people,
they don't care about how
other people perceive them.
I am not doing what I do
because I'm worried about
other people's judgements.
And the people who are at the bottom,
the people who never get ahead,
the people who continually struggle,
are the ones who are always
afraid of how other people
are going to judge them.
You're going to make mistakes.
You will try things that will not work out
and the key is, you need to
start building that muscle.
You have to start building
that experimentation muscle,
because when you put something
out there and it doesn't work
what happens is you grow stronger.
When you take an idea from your head
and you put it out there and you try,
every time you do that, you grow stronger.
Every time you care a little bit less
about somebody else's opinion
of you, you grow stronger,
and you have a choice every single day.
Every single day you have a choice
to either grow stronger
or shrink back down.
Every time you get an idea
and you do something about it,
even if it doesn't
work, you grow stronger,
you build that muscle
so you can do it again
and next time with more power.
Every time you get an idea
and you don't do something
about it and you shrink
down and you tell yourself
why you can't do it,
and you're worried about
other people's judgements,
then you get weaker
and you reinforce that story.
Either way, you're reinforcing
a story to yourself
that you can do this
and you can be strong,
or you can't do this and you're weak.
And every day you have an
opportunity to reinforce
either story, and I want
you to start playing here.
I want you to start feeling
like you are powerful.
I want you to stop caring
about what other people think
of you and I want you to
start, when you get an idea,
doing something about it.
And it doesn't just happen
overnight, at least from
my experience it isn't
just like you know what?
Tomorrow, I don't care
what anybody thinks of me.
You could say that, but
actually believe it?
I don't know.
But you can do it in steps.
You may not be able to go
and lift this huge weight
but you can work your way
up there and every day
you get a little bit stronger
and so every little tiny
micro-win is still a win
that makes you stronger
and lets you move one step forward.
The second thing about
experimentation I think
holds people back is they
feel it has to be perfect,
it has to be the perfect thing,
it has to be all worked out
before they ever get started,
and that is not the path.
What you have to understand
is most of the learning
that you'll get, most of the
figuring out what it's going to be
comes from actually trying it.
Whatever idea you have, you
can't just come up with it
in your head and write it
down on a piece of paper,
you have to go and start
doing it and you'll learn
by the doing of how to adjust.
So as an example, one
of my instructors here
trying to dance salsa
wanted us to practice
storytelling in our classes,
so instead of coming in
and just teaching how
to do a turn in salsa,
she's giving a story around
it, maybe it's her own story
of how she learned, maybe
it's another student's story
about how they learned it,
and the difficulties they may have had,
and how they came through
it, because her goal
in being an instructor here
is not just to teach people
how to be dancers and
learn a certain move,
but to build people's confidence,
to strengthen their soul,
to become better humans, to
take what they learned here,
the feeling they get, and
have that have a ripple effect
out on the rest of their
life, that's her goal,
that's what she wants for her students.
She wants to be one of the
best instructors of all time
for her students because
she had a profound impact
on their life, and not just
teaching them subject matter.
And so she experimented, she had this idea
and she did something
about it and at the start,
it wasn't working so well.
Her stories were long, they
didn't have the right theme,
it was hard for people to
understand, she was summarizing
instead of going deep into the material.
It wasn't a great first start,
but that's to be expected.
And she got some feedback and
there was one particularly
harsh message that came from
one of the students that said,
"I would rather go with
this other instructor
because this one is, you spend
too much time storytelling,
and I'm not getting value from
it," and I showed it to her
and it was really, really
you know, hard to take in
because when you know that
you're not doing a good job
and then somebody shows it to you, right,
here's what this person
said, it can be really hard,
but to her credit she didn't
stop and she kept working
and she kept getting better
and she kept practicing
and she kept adjusting
and she continued to
experiment, to the point where,
earlier this week, she
had an amazing class.
One where everybody left on such a high
that they're going to remember
for the rest of their week,
the rest of their month,
maybe the rest of the year,
that class they had with her
and she transformed in the
class from just being a dance
teacher to somebody who was
having a profound impact
on the lives of her students
and that happens in
everything that you do.
You are going to suck
at the start, expect it.
That's okay, but don't
let that hold you back
from trying and experimenting.
You go out out there, you
try something, you adjust,
you tweak it to see if you like it.
So many of you have
these plans in your head
of these great ideas that you have
and you do nothing with them.
Get them out and try.
Stop worrying about what people think.
Build that muscle that
gets stronger, and realize
that the learning comes from the doing,
not just the thinking.
So the question then today is I'm curious
what are you guys
experimenting with right now
that's pushing you to be better,
that's pushing through some
limited beliefs you might have.
What's the hardest thing you're
experimenting on right now.
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in on the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Norz Szanto.
Nora, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really, really, really,
really appreciate it and
I hope you're enjoying.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, if
you want a little bit more
inspiration on experimenting,
I think these bonus clips will help you.
- I stopped listening
to music after Kurt died
because it was so
emotional just hearing it.
I didn't want to hear it
on the radio, I didn't want
to play it, I didn't want
to join another band,
and then after a while I realize
that it was the one thing
that was going to help
me get through everything
so I started writing lyrics
and I started writing songs
and I went and recorded this demo tape.
♫ When I talk about it
♫ Carries on reasons only knew
A record company called and said,
"Hey, we want to release your record."
I said, "That's a demo, that's not a band.
That's a thing I did
by myself in five days.
- And you play every instrument?
- Yeah, so then I started to think,
Wow, maybe I will try this.
I've never been the singer of a band.
- Was it a tough transition
from drummer to front man?
- Absolutely, it took years,
man, it took a long time.
- It's interesting the way it starts,
there's some moaning at the beginning.
- Of which one?
- The first song on the record.
- Birthday.
- Don't know the titles,
no one told me the titles,
just heard the record, it is called,
look at that exclusive, perfect.
(laughter)
Yeah, you said birthday in it a lot.
But that's a very mature
progression sonically
to add those moaning sounds as
opposed to being that Disney
person you've been known
to be over the years.
- Sure, but I mean I'm
- [Interviewer] It's not a bad thing.
- No, of course, I think
it's more me being able to
experiment, you know, going into the booth
and actually having the
confidence of actually being like,
"Alright, let me try this,
let me see if this works,"
and messing around with
melodies or just harmonies,
or as you say, moaning.
- It was, isn't it, kind of ?
- I guess that's the right
term for it in a way.
- [Interviewer] I think so.
- But yeah, no in a way,
I think I really was
able to just play and that was fun.
- You write in your book,
'cause you're talking
about the art of writing and
planning routes and everything,
you say, "Magic exists, but
often requires some planning."
But you were talking about
writing, I think it seems also
apply to the music even
like you have some planning,
but there's that room for improv.
- Well said, absolutely so.
Yeah, all that effort of
study and I always said
that the early records that
the three of us made together,
we were experimenting, we
were learning how to play
our instruments, we were
learning how to write songs,
we were learning how to
arrange, especially through say,
Farewell to Kings Hemispheres,
we were learning so much
about arrangement and
orchestration in the sense
of a three piece rock band
all of that gathered together
and then by say, Moving Pictures was 1980,
so we've been together
six years by that time
and then we gelled and
all of those studies,
all of those courses of
study that we went through
together with pure innocence
and pure enthusiasm
suddenly they became a unified
approach that Moving Pictures
and from then on carried for
us and then as that time,
even from that time, yeah,
we continued to experiment
absolutely with different kinds of songs,
different kinds of arrangements,
orchestrations of all
kinds, different producers,
there's another good example.
You can get comfortable
working with the same producer
and some people do their whole career
but we always felt we
wanted new brains to pick
and new criticisms and new enthusiasms,
just new opinions.
- In late 2012, I worked on a
book launch for Tim Ferriss.
He wrote a book called The Four Hour Chef.
It was his third book, it
was published by Amazon
and because it was published
by Amazon, we found out
at the very last minute,
about six weeks before launch,
that it was going to be banned
by every major bookstore
in the United States
and this is pretty much
the worst thing that can happen to you
if you're doing a traditional book launch,
'cause that's where books are sold.
So how do we hit The New
York Times Best Seller List?
How do we move copies if all
the traditional marketing stuff
is out the window?
That leaves growth hacking, right?
How do we do this, how do we
treat this book like a start up
that we're creating from nothing?
One of the first things we did
was a bit torrent giveaway.
We gave away something
like 250 pages of the book.
Videos, photos, all sorts of extra stuff.
It ended up getting downloaded I think
about three million times.
It drove 250,000 people
to the Amazon page.
It was the single most effective thing.
I've worked on close
to a dozen bestsellers.
It was the single most effective
thing that I've ever seen
in the history of book marketing,
and it came from giving
a sizeable portion of the book
away and so it was this proof
for me that the traditional marketing,
the untrackable, the untested
things aren't working anymore
and we want to experiment,
and we want to try new things.